ça n'est plus un secret pour personne
jalil lespert et laeticia hallyday sont
fous l'un de l'autre
anniversaires saint valentin ils passent
tout leur temps ensemble et le
réalisateur sont bien avoir fait oublier
johnny dans le coeur de laëtitia si la
jolie blonde a bien évidemment le droit
de refaire sa vie les fans ont encore du
mal à accepter que jalil et pris la
place du rockeur cette semaine valident
publié une photo sur son compte
instagram une faute au volant d'une
voiture cabriolet ac cobra est ce qui a
mis le feu aux poudres c'est que cette
voiture appartenait à johnny un bolide
qu'il s'était offert en 2016 les fans du
chanteur n'ont fait part de leur
indignation aux commentaires
il n'aura jamais la classe de johnny ou
encore pauvre johnny il ne méritait pas
autant de mépris
pourtant laetitia les conflits dans une
interview que johnny tenait énormément à
cette voiture et qu'elle ne la vendrai
jamais la qualifiant comme la voiture de
ses rêves alors jeanine espère au volant
de la voiture de john hitchcock les fans
du rockeur comprenez vous leur colère
pour des manches au piège
moi je vous dis j'aurais la chance
d'avoir une femme qui a des voitures
d'un défunt mari mais oui je les prends
tous mais c'est absolument scandaleux
ensemble depuis trois jours est
changement et à chaque fois monsieur va
se régaler avec les voitures de palu
dieu c'est le nôtre dû à tous johnny
hallyday mais tous pas aux voitures
non mais moi
à tanger en complément les voitures et
ses traits à johnny je suis d'accord
mais elle est bon allez plus avec lui la
voiture mais il est plus là c'était
c'est un grand monsieur et c'est sur six
vit dans la maison aussi avec celle des
rampes à sketches mais alors servir à
quoi leur mais alors et alors elle est
la plus de mari elle dit plus parce
qu'elle a appartenu à johnny téléphone
je suis d'accord vous avez tous aimé
jolly moi j'aimais donnait pas plus que
ça j'ai aimé ses chansons mais je
n'étais pas un fan mais c'est pas parce
que quelqu'un roule d'un sébastien sait
si elles en ont la voiture quelqu'un
d'autre va revenir il déjà à moi ni
n'importe quoi vous vous ça vous choque
ah bah non mais moi moi ça mais moi ça
me choque pas du tout pas du tout dire
mais ça me choque pas du tout moi je dis
que c'est normal les familles vous
comprenez pas visible oui match je je je
comprends à 100% les fans et un monde
oui basse il faut pas tourner la bouche
c'est la vérité alors les mois
m'attendais à mieux
mais non mais parce que en fait je les
comprends parce que ça restera de ce
quotidien restera toute sa vie avec
cette image de johnny faut qu'elle
comprenne ça donc les voitures
franchement ça se fait pas ce
soissonnais ce que ça c'est pas aux gens
de comprendre aussi c'est que les gens
que ça peut [ __ ] aux gens en fait ce
sont ces que lé canadien c'est dans le
symbole oui c'est le symbole le monde a
résumé que barbara john wick et c'est le
symbole mais et après et alors il
voulait donner le nom mais il ya tant d
il ya deux bagnoles au garage à la
bentley
elle avait il a profité alors mais les
motos aux six mois je suis profondément
choquée je suis profondément choqué il
ya une phrase qui dit les morts
continuent à vivre dans le coeur dit moi
je trouve que c'est profondément
scandaleux
au programme aujourd'hui ces gens paient
bordelais sais-je encore et du coup
voilà et moi je trouve ça profondément
scandaleux parce que johnny n'a pas
donné son accord pour qu'il prenne ses
voitures
tu disais je suis désolé je connais sont
d'accord mais il aurait dû d'abord avant
l objection bois le verre à moitié plein
franchement c'est un honneur et honore
la mémoire de johnny un conte du genre
mais c'est presqu'en d'algérie t6 lui
vendait la voiture de john il assuré
jean paul sartre avec les dettes savait
encore plus cher que la bagnole je
faisais moi le problème le problème en
fait je crois que c'est jalil lespert en
fait il a commencé déjà quand on l'a vu
se recueillir sur la tombe
c'est un certain temps maintenant d'être
dans cette et toute cette voiture vous
avez raison c'est le symbole ya beaucoup
de voitures qu'on connaît pas tellement
cette voiture vous avez montré la photo
tout à l'heure avec eux c'est la voiture
préférée du scandale dont il aurait fait
face à un autre mois n'a pas voir aussi
une façon de rendre hommage à deux mais
cette voie là on ne peut pas dire qu'il
y aurait été content que la nation
continue à rouler parce qu'ils s'abîment
vous savez à quel âge et pas toujours
été tendre avec franchement qu'elle
fasse vie alors excusez moi johnny t'es
blessé un peu il a adoré ces bagnoles
idriss et qu'il aiderait ces motos et
quand on aime les voitures et les motos
il ya une chose qu'on doit faire et
benjamin vous m'avez convaincu je change
de vols à la tire
j'ai lui dire qu'il demande en mariage
n'a lésé j'avais beau me dire qu'il
vient d'avoir une demande en mariage
[Musique]
les deux vont bientôt se marier
ah oui vont bien ensemble une demande en
mariage en être mechri à l'abri les
demander en mariage il a vu le garage
avec l'approbation de la burqa n'a donc
lie donc ces bâtonnets c'est une info ça
fait un faux donc jalil lespert aurait
demandé en mariage et weeds hier j'ai la
demande a été faite sur une plage
qu'avant il a demandé l'autorisation aux
filles de laëtitia qui ont donné leur
approbation et donc de là elle a dit
alors grand oui c'est comme dirait
l'autre mondiaux quelles sont vos
sources à dire qu'elle n'a jamais cessé
benjamin comment journaliste n'a jamais
mais non c'est non sans une certaine
pression c'est une triste c'est pour les
autres enfants des cités prévue pour au
bas mot là là je sais pas moi je les
ferai moi je vous dis franchement si
elle est heureux mais regarde moi ce que
j'ai envie juste dire c'est qu'il ya les
enfants jalil lespert et pour eux c'est
pas trés trés rugbyman répondrait et je
ne passais pas très gai pour eux parce
que leur papa est très très loin
donc quand on voit ces images je trouve
que rachel est très proche de celle qui
est l'âme à un enfant avec jalil et donc
c'est vrai que c'est très très triste
pour la petite fille qui ne voit pas son
papa qui veut voir en photo avec les
bois mais enfin ils voient pas leur mère
anne aux états unis sont pas malheureux
pour eux ici il faut apprendre à vivre
avec jeux d'hier s'est passé mais oui
juste sérieusement je compose peser
rachel c'est vrai que pour le coup ça
puisse palper son enfant n'est pas très
grand avec une autre petite fille je
n'ai vécu et c'est très très tout le
monde l'a vécu
non je dis je les ai vécus et quand on a
un enfant avec une personne et que cette
personne s'occupe plus de l'enfant de
quelqu'un d'autre je peux pas vous dire
que la souffrance qu'on a dans le cul
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait on savait de
vivre alors non je dis pas ça je dis
juste que le papa doit s'occuper de tout
le monde et partagent beaucoup de
couples aux gens qui la voient pas
beaucoup
bah écoutes je passais pas que tu vis la
cub cet accord bagnols annonce enfin une
antiphrase je sais pas si c'est si ça
sera la conclusion à tous âges et
rêverait conclure c'est vrai que le
second condamné java groupe beaucoup
cassé du sucre sur le dos de laëtitia
moi je crois que si johnny si il est
mort en aimant sa femme et en voulant
qu'elle soit heureuse aujourd'hui elle a
retrouvé le bonheur passionnés tous
s'est paré l'agencé moi pareil mon ex
mari vit de l'autre côté de l'océan
atlantique
à un moment donné quand les parents ils
se séparent intelligemment quand il
reste intelligent aussi bien auprès des
enfants que de leur ex tout va bien